let's go for another
another three minute game
mateo lopez from colombia
interesting very interesting
um okay let's go for the uh
for the london and once he goes
once ago g goes g6 i'll go for
the the old um
h4 attack
which is actually holding up pretty well
i think in practice like
i think castling is actually considered
a mistake here
because h5 is just very dangerous
followed by sacking the exchange after
knight h5
which means that what he did here with
uh c6 is more sensible
just making a wedding move and now h5a
is there's not that much point to it
seeing as black hasn't castled
so we'll go for this instead which is
pretty standard um
bishop f5
yeah i guess that's reasonable i'll go
95
then i'll go f3 hinting at it later at
g4 g4 or uh
or um f4 uh sir g4 e4
uh yeah queen b6 is very reasonable
i think i'm sacking upon here though
if um queen b2
rook b1 queen c2 queen c2 bishop c2
rook b7 i do have a pretty active
rook on the 7th um
and his extra pawn is
really weak whenever he wants to
castle king said he probably has to
to suck upon so it seemed
a very reasonable sack for me um bishop
h6 i guess is quite reasonable intending
a later um 97.
guess i'll just castle for now
um seems that
it's pretty far away from creating any
sort of dangerous dangerous threats
against my king so
um oh wait a second did i miss g4
here
i didn't actually miss g4 because there
was
hd fg bishop e4
and then attacking attacking the rook
and
if i move the rook he would have time to
prevent
yeah that was that was a bit sloppy not
good to consider it alone
yeah rooted for preparing knight d7
very very sensible i think i'll go
knight
a4 now kicking the queen away
queen d8 was the only only available
square
knight c5 seems reasonable
and i'm thinking if he goes b6 which is
the most natural move
i'll drop the knight yeah knight a6 rook
c8 doesn't seem to be much
i'll drop the knight back to d3 and
claim
that the knight is better replaced than
um
on d3 than it was on c3 which i think
almost certainly it is it has a lot more
prospects here of jumping to let's say
e5
and maybe even b4
certainly have ideas of going g4 now
um as a matter of fact i think that's
well what i'll do
yeah it seems reasonable so it takes
tanks i give up the e4 square for the
bishop
but i do open the df file i have the
option of going
uh of going g5 later on or even to go
knight f2
at some point don't harass the bishop
knight f8 seems a bit too passive
don't really know what's what's the
point here
um knight f2 now i have two ideas first
one is the most obvious
which is taken e4 the other one i think
is even stronger which is to go [ __ ]
based six
and actually this means that i'm
trapping
trapping the rook um just for sure
i'm not going to i'm not going to take
the
protect the rook since i have so many
positional trumps here
and the bishop is so strong that it
seemed seemed unnecessary
there should be six not fe six queen d6
is a queen mate
okay uh interesting strategic fight
there
uh and uh yeah when it all
sort of uh flared up then it was clear
that um i had the upper upper hand also
with the
this clock uh clock ticking down that's
certainly uh certainly interesting
okay okay